but can't season three is a really great
show and I'm really enjoying it but is
it a complete flop the evidence suggests
so
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
I have to say this video gives me no
pleasure I really really want this show
to succeed because I actually think it's
great I'm really really enjoying it no
don't get me wrong there are a few bits
in it that are irritating me
um there's been a few points and I've
already discussed in other videos that
are to retaining but they're mild
irritations the show is genuinely
interesting it has loads of Easter eggs
going back to previous Seasons we're
learning bits and Bobs about the
previous TNG episodes that we know and
love and it's just interesting I
desperately want to know what's
happening but
is it a flop well thanks to Bob one of
our lovely subscribers he sent me some
bits of information and it doesn't look
good so
Flix Patrol is a website that does the
top 10 shows for each streaming platform
and other things each day you can go on
there and you can see whatever show that
day is the most popular the top 10 top
10 movies top 10 TV shows
so we would hope that Star Trek Picard
would be in that top 10 on the day that
it was released
it wasn't
so Star Trek Picard did not make the top
10 in the United States on the day that
it was released the Thursday just gone
the 9th of March
but unfortunately it gets a little bit
worse than that if we look at the
numbers for worldwide audiences for
um Star Trek and Powerman plus we find
that actually Star Trek Discovery is
higher in the charts than Picard it
actually reaches um number 16 in the
list and just one below NCIS and two
below Teen Wolf
strange new worlds goes in at number 27
and Picard number 37. now the worldwide
numbers don't really give us a total
picture because for example Picard is
actually available on
um Amazon Prime and most of the rest of
the world I watch an Amazon Prime I
don't watch it on Powerman Plus
so I would expect those numbers to be
lower but they are significantly lower
even when compared to other shows in
this list have actually also appear on
other channels for example Criminal
Minds in the United States is much
higher on this list than Picard Criminal
Minds also appears on Disney Around the
World
so you would expect there to be a
similar effect on its numbers you would
expect Criminal Minds to be lower
because people around the rest of the
world probably watch it on Disney
but it doesn't seem to have that effect
so what is going on
well as I said in the United States
where this airs first you would expect
those numbers to be good you would
expect it to be really high
but it doesn't even make the top ten
so
even if this is a massive hit for Prime
and everyone watches it on prime prime
perhaps the rest of the world maybe
Prime are very very happy
Paramount aren't going to be and for
them at very least it is a huge flop
now Karma plus is desperately trying to
get new subscribers that's what they're
trying to do they're trying to grow this
small platform at the moment it is one
of the smaller of the streaming service
platforms
so Picard is supposed to be one of those
shows that do that that bring
subscribers to Paramount Plus
it's not working so for them at very
least this has been a huge failure if
you spend this much money on a season of
television and it does not make your top
10 on the David's release
that's a problem
but why are people not watching the show
I generally think this is a hangover
from the first and second Seasons now
again if you are regular side tracker
you'll know I am not a fan of the first
and second seasons of Star Trek Picard
at all you see I I actually hate them so
much I can't even I struggle to get the
words out
there was so many problems with the
first and second seasons
I genuinely said to you guys if this
third season doesn't meet at least basic
expectations I was tempted to walk away
from Star Trek and I am a Trekkie I'm a
guy that has loved Star Trek my entire
life
but I'm so angry particularly look
Picard season one was just not very well
written Picard season two was a waste of
time and actually made me angry they
built it up so much that it was going to
be this amazing show that was going to
explain so many things about q and have
really great things with John delances
and actually I absolutely adore and it
was going to explain so much and then it
just didn't it had the Borg but it
didn't they were like an offshoot of the
Borg that again didn't make sense and
actually if you think about it go back
and watch it if she'd have just gone
it's me
don't fire there's this bad thing that's
going to happen I'm gonna help
everything else that happens is
completely irrelevant it's the fact that
girati attacked that's the problem so
anyway look I'm going on a rant there
now because it made me so angry but
honestly it was rubbish
now Picard season 3 isn't rubbish it's a
really really exciting the characters
that we've got are actually finally
being used well we're bringing back TNG
characters we have a genuine mystery
that not only makes sense but it's I'm
desperate to find out what's going on
now there's been a few little
irritations I wasn't a massive fan of
the nebula space babies thing in the
last episode I'm sorry if that's a
spoiler for you guys but I won't tell
you any more than that to not ruin it
but I was not a fan
I'm not a big fan of um a few other
things from the series but it is
genuinely brilliant
so yesterday I put a poll on my channel
because again I'm trying to figure out
why people aren't watching and
the results were to say the least
interesting So currently I have had 489
votes now remember this is a Sci-Fi
channel only subscribers to my channel
have seen this poll
so it is sci-fi fans that have voted now
61 say they are really enjoying Star
Trek Picard brilliant only four percent
said they're not enjoying it but out of
the 489 votes 34
a third of sci-fi fans
say they're not watching it and some of
the comments I'm getting
they're not good
but most people just have basically said
I have no intention of watching it I've
watched the first two seasons and yeah
I'm not falling for it again it's going
to be a load of rubbish and I ain't
interested now there are a few other
people actually that say look I haven't
got around to it yet I'm waiting for it
to be done and I'm gonna binge it at the
end but that's going to be a relatively
small number
this show should be in the top 10 in the
United States on its Premiere day on
Thursdays and the fact that it isn't
is a problem
now I went in and checked the 10th of
march yesterday I've checked today's
numbers because I just wanted to make
sure that they weren't sort of like 24
hours behind that you know when a
Premiere comes on maybe it's just
there's a bit of a lag
it doesn't reach that list either it's
not in that top 10 either
so I cannot help but take these numbers
and think Paramount plus they're going
to be very very disappointed
but what does that mean potentially for
the future of Star Trek well
it's not good Picard is obviously coming
to an end we've just had the
announcement the discovery is going to
be coming to an end of season five I
have told you lots and lots of rumors
that apparently Paramount are very keen
to get Star Trek away from Alex kurtzman
and these poor numbers
now we've always assumed that Star Trek
was a big hit for Parliament and that
they were very happy with it but I've
heard lots of rumors that in fact Amazon
Prime tried to get out of the whole deal
with Star Trek and Picard following the
first season and would have done if they
could
this has been apparently a very
expensive experiment and one that has
not excited anything like enough fans
to keep it going
so for the future of Star Trek
it's not looking good
but let's just hope that Paramount trust
the franchise and that maybe they're
thinking about a little bit of a reboot
a reboot or a restart
and then maybe we can move past the
coach menus
because hey tell you what if Terry
metallis is allowed to show run future
Star Trek shows and he can deliver
something of this quality
that the quality of pecan season 3
we could still get a really amazing
future for Star Trek and we can maybe
put some of the disappointments
behind us
let's hope that's what powerman's plan
is because let's be honest
Voyager was the end of Star Trek for a
very very long time
Paramount will put Star Trek out to
pasture if he thinks it needs to
sometimes people you just get sick of a
franchise they get Trek fatigue
I think Disney are enjoying that at the
moment with Star Wars fatigue
and we could lose Star Trek from our
screens entirely for another decade if
Paramount don't come up with a plan to
save the franchise
if you have not watched Picard season 3
yet
do it watch it you will love it
out of the people that voted two-thirds
of people are absolutely loving this
series only four percent said they're
not liking it please remember that
out of the third that aren't watching it
give it a chance it deserves it
guys get to the comments tell me exactly
what you think about Picard being a
complete flop am I reading these numbers
right or is there maybe another way of
looking at it I'd love you guys to get
into the comments and tell me exactly
what you're thinking this is a debate
not a dictatorship
so I'd love to know
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you will never miss any of our new
videos also you can go to patreon.com
forward slash Sidetrack and you can for
a small fee join the channel and get all
or most of our videos a little bit
quicker than everybody else and without
the adverts
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
thank you